right six times six times six times six
times six times six times six times six
in exponential in exponential notation
so what's going on over here well we
have six multiplied by itself how many
times let's see that's six times one
then six times two is that that's six
type well it's not six times two it's
six times itself two times remember six
times itself two times would be 36 six
times two would only be 12 so we've won
6-2 6-3 6-4 656 is six sixes seven six
is eight sixes so we're multiplying six
by itself eight times to write this in
exponential notation we would say that
this is equal to six
this is equal to six to the to the
eighth power which is literally equal to
six times six times six times six times
six times six times six times six now I
want to make it very clear this is not
this is not this is not equal to six
times eight six times eight six times
eight will only be 48 six to the eighth
power is a super huge number six times
six is thirty-six and you're gonna
multiply that times six which is what
that's like
thirty-six times that's what 216 and
then you keep multiplying it by six you
get some huge number here this number
right here it's worthwhile to point out
this number is huge this number is huge
this number right here not so huge it is
not huge so don't get confused if you
see six to the eighth power it's six
times itself eight times
not six times eight